je suis de retour en martinique pour du
sport à l'invitation de l'association
pour la promotion des anciennes gloires
axée sur le sport les anciennes gloires
du sport mais qui qui a souhaité mettre
de quelques autres personnes à l'honneur
non je fais partie j'en suis très fier
très flatté et d'autant plus que je
trouve ce travail de qui pour nous
rappeler qu' il y a eu
monsieur x que peut-être les jeunes
générations ne connaissent pas mais qui
a été une gloire du football
je trouve cette démarche de de rappel de
mémoire je trouve ça tout à fait louable
donc c'est un tournoi de foot il ya
diverses associations alors il il ya des
entreprises des particuliers tout
tournoi et donc je vais être en train de
évidemment je n'y participe pas mes
succès avec beaucoup d'intérêt et puis
voilà je fais partie des invités donc je
souhaite comme à remercier l'association
pour le travail qu'elle fait et puis
aussi pour m'avoir invité ce dont je
suis tout à fait fière